whether popping off after a win a key
charge or a Relentless barrage of
in-game taunts the Tekken disrespect
afficionados know how to leave a lasting
impression it's not just about defeating
an opponent it's about asserting
dominance showcasing superiority and at
times even humiliating the foe in the
eyes of the audience the levels of
respect here from the Tekken Community
while rooted in sportsmanship recognizes
and even celebrates this unique facet of
the game Spectators eagerly anticipate
moments of disrespect adding an extra
layer of excitement to
tournaments welcome to another ooto TV
special this is part two of the most
disrespectful moments in Tekken
tournaments Tech into those 2D games cuz
you couldn't hang in Tech
[Music]
anymore not only are we going to beat
Bronson then we going to take his
girlfriend that's how it works you don't
understand me but you're going to need
it oh my God man
PCO PCO do not pretty hyped I think he's
going to lose steam pretty soon cuz he's
pretty old yeah he's pretty old man he
can't be oh where you going giant swing
where you check that out your dead
son oh just like you called it down 411
I like the way he's using it nice air
conversion again going to get a shine oh
wow getting the wall get him oh no break
oh here's a 5050 get down
back wow what a off you better calm down
on man we got to return you to the home
in good shape we don't want them to come
after us and I think we should remind
both of these players again this is
three out of five oh my God
sh oh no D why is he pting you know what
I'm waiting for p to just slap on
exactly right mouth a
jar yo you going to hit him with the
RDC Bronson is spinning on the floor
he's H three stes he hit the hi High
though for sure that is definitely his
voice in crack now into a running power
B I'm looking to close it out with a
perfect baby down back to again oh the
OE k not going to happen here comes
PCO oh nice duck there I like the
pressure then puko just backing up just
in
time
it game two goes to BR so nice just like
extends the
lead take off the shirt punko take off
that shirt wow sounding a little gross
up there Bron TR begging him to take off
his shirt me Bron
okay here's the pressure what's he going
to go for oh this is so scary nice
H one round oh man and pko should be oh
no he drops
ITB to take it two to one po takes off
the jacket you thought it was
over BR don't do it uh-oh yo I take my
off
too oh what a duck and what a Punisher
from Bronson nice all right going to get
this Power Bomb all right what's he
going to go for this time offense in his
favor oh oh SM them and that's guarante
arrow and Bron to Tren takes it with the
race Drive ground throw
[Applause]
[Music]
Victory oh boy oh look at this it's
spend the rrive immediately thr a Crouch
Das one isan from the Philippines here
we
go for the r d makes up nice patience
there from from do right here and of
course gets that round as well he can
get that light back he's one of those
characters in the game who can
regenerate will but look at this now in
Rage oh my goodness the End Mill a chunk
out of Doan's life here we go looking a
little stronger now is Philipines now
the be pick seems to be working and
Indonesia still on the defensive there
we goes two of the back ones the power
crushes that's guaranteed to your back
against the wall oh wow unusually
hitting that wall standing for was a
little too far there's the wall standing
one plus two here and the Philippines
just getting himself some reasonable
damage right here against Indonesia wow
and the power crash off of the hunting
bear stance gets himself two rounds in
punishment as well oh my goodness a well
placed rage art from Indonesia this is
going to be massive damage for but
here's the question is it enough to kill
because it looked like Philippines was
in the middle of a stance doing
so oh no not quite a SL of life left for
the right here and a long range be head
but gets him that win three straight
rounds and look at this it's very
compact play so far from in and it's all
working so well the low are coming in do
what he going to be able to do his
pushing all the way to the wall there's
the bear claw oh my goodness a rage
grive as well good conversion goes with
the key charge oh my goodness massive
damage look at this and Philippines just
lying down one poke away he is one poke
away oh and it has to be the bare Laser
cannon getting himself and look at that
sitting down again and again is trying
to find his way out of the corner right
here double be claw on the floor out and
that huge round out takes the first game
and Indonesia is almost en rage great
block and Indonesia again racking up the
damage oh my goodness a little too
greedy there for Philippines and now
Indonesia tying things up with two
rounds of piece literally pushing
Indonesia back against oh there's the
pounce and he's closing in on the damage
oh and this is going to be it it had to
be this one oh my goodness missing very
wildly and Indonesia just ducking in
front of him eats one of the hits of the
bare Pistons oh my goodness now
Philippines with two wins up that was a
crazy exchange right there didn't quite
go according to Wild the second hit
knocks him down both play is almost life
the 112 puts the Phil pin in the red
right here there's the for one plus two
a little bit too far and Indonesia gets
that ground very nice work so far for
you now ladies and gentlemen forward two
right there and now Indonesia looking
for that kill oh but the ra Drive comes
out for the Philippines and that is it
two rounds for the Phil that balcony
right there portal Philippines looking
quite dominant right here with that
early pound on all the way to halflife
just with those folks out of hunting
bear St 10 seconds spent already and
here we go Philippines still with that
lifely beautiful D on that third hit
Indonesia on the red right here oh the
low bear claw and the ra however comes
out Indonesia still alive right there
putting him in the corner dirty boxing
comes in the combos are coming out the
Philippines is in the red 30 seconds
left oh great evasion on the dirty
boxing and the Philippines get them get
that win three wins against Indonesia 3
to one again very hyp set for just as
what we
[Music]
expected oh he back but I do I do I do I
I punish wi hey don't talk don't talk
punish that was punish you push the but
I punish pushing the Play Don't Push the
play won't get punched stop doing
okay ouch the big jump punch looks like
liquid from New York
oh we need to
OA with the pop
off real with the pop
off a block
nice I can't do this get out of here man
oh he dropped it oh wait a minute I
think that was a reset oh wait
a this is getting butt ugly internet oh
oh oh my god
wow getting
[Laughter]
high guy's out of his mind
security get this guy out of here man
it's 11 right now
what what hara's loving
[Applause]
this look at his
face oh my
[Applause]
[Laughter]
God
[Applause]
we need a medic we need so much for real
guys I realized fighting I got the taser
on
him right
slide really
oh man look at his face what is going on
through that
head
uhoh uh o the pop off ooh and look at
Pok chop no no response I've never
seen oh no response from Pok chop the
crowd stands up oh and he oh oh and
the okay moral support from poke oh he
needs that that sweat I have never SE
all all right there he goes never seen
anyone pop off over tying it up yeah
popping off over a tie nice work crazy
good
point wow that looking good what a quick
uh quick rebuttal so 3-2 right now yeah
32 it's getting
close Man real looks like he's really
taking this
seriously uhoh this is Evo Grand finals
for
[Music]
real oh my
God oh my God that's a gift already what
does that even do for anybody that's a
gift already cter hit oh no why are you
ducking oh oh oh my oh good luck
oh so it's tied up the
wave is he yelling
Trill oh he broke the
wall punish that oh that was a really
important game
43 what's his thing shrimp I don't know
what he's doing he looks like a T-Rex
right now we need a
translator can we get a translator
please oh no he found out the camera's
here uhoh
no round
brown liid looked at me he made eye
contact like what the round round no
rounds this
round man oh what a
block like I said ain't no
liar no round BR
bab uh what did we just
witness uh man of his word end your
shift now you can end your shift
now I know I know what I'm talking about
I've won I've won tournaments on I've
won more tournaments than you'll ever
enter thanks for watching be sure to
[Music]
subscribe
oh